JoJosée Legault, Martine Biron t
MiMichel David bonsoir.
OnOn parle beaucoup de camionnae
dedepuis quelques jours
évévidemment, on va voir des
imimages, il se dirige je le
rarappelle vers Ottawa samedi. l
y y en a qui ont prévu des
dédérapages, d'autres non.
AtAttention une chose à l la fo.
MaMais ce qui est sûr,r, au dépt
cece qui était une colèrere cone
l'l'obligation vaccinale c'est
asassez élargi à t toutes les
obobligations sanitaires. Vous
avavez comme moi entendu plusies
cacamionnages dirent on n'est ps
dadans cette histoire-là..
- - Oui il y a quand mêmeme 90 s
cacamionneurs canadiens qui sont
vavaccinés. C'est clair que c'et
unune minorité. C'est une minoré
ququi n'est pas étonnante. Elle
s's'inscrit dans un mouvement
bebeaucoup plus large. Qui est
l'l'opposition au vaccin, mais
dederrièrere cette obligation ct
unune obligation au vaccin.
PrPrévoir les affiches qui
tatapissent les camions. Toute
cecette constellation d'extrêmes
drdroites, raciste et trumpiste
ququi est en train de se greffeà
çaça. Ça ça inquiètete énormémet
leles 90 % des camionneurs au
CaCanada qui n'ont rien à v voir
avavec ça. On peut le rassurer e
ququoi qu'il arrive, à O Ottawan
esespèrere qu'il n'y aura pas de
grgrabuge. Je pense que les gens
cocomprennent très s bien et sot
cacapables de dissocier entre ce
pepetit groupe la très s vocal t
trtrès s bruyant et la presque
tototalité des camionneurs
fifinalement.
- - Martin on peut avoir un
mamalaise par rapport à
l'l'obligation vaccinale, mais
c'c'est une chose ça et c'est ue
chchose que d'aller là-b-bas ete
didire qu'on va faire un spectae
dedevant le Parlement.
- - C'est le Parlement canadien,
c'c'est une liste très s import,
lele potentiel de dérapage est
trtrès s élevé. Ce n'est pas jue
le nom vacciné, on a rassemblé
prpresque tous les insatisfaitse
nonotre société. C'est un
momouvement qui part de l'Ouestt
ququi a trouvé des gens en
OnOntario. Il y a moins de
QuQuébécois et moins de
cacamionneurs délestent mais la
ququestion des mouvements radicx
ququi sont en train de prendre n
ototage ce mouvement là. . C'ese
ququi est inquiétant et ce qui
fafait que ce soir on ne peut ps
vrvraiment prédire ce qui va se
papasser en fin de semaine. Mais
onon sait tous que le danger est
llà..
- - D'ailleurs les policiers sot
susur leurs gardes.
- - Bien entendu, moi je ne suis
papas convaincu du tout que les
gegens vont prendre d'assaut le
PaParlement que vous avez pris
d'd'assaut le Capitole. Mais
sisimplement la présence d'un
nonombre considérable de gros
vévéhicules qui vont se stationr
àà O Ottawa pendant on ne sait s
cocombien de temps ils arrivent
sasamedi. Il est évident que ça
gégénèrere un problèmeme consid.
IlIl y a toute la dimension
popolitique de ça. On voit que
MoMonsieur Trudeau tient son bo,
ilil a constaté pendant la
cacampagne électorale que la
vavaccination obligatoire c'estn
bobon filon pour lui, ça m'a bin
seservi à c ce moment-là. . Il t
quque s'embarrassent Monsieur
auautour. Alors c'est un jeu qui
esest dangereux. Quand tout le
momonde trouve un avantage à u e
sisituation qui fait exploser, a
nene finit pas toujours comme on
avavait voulu.
- - Monsieur autour devait parlr
mamais il a retardé son point de
prpresse à 1 18 heures. C'est pr
çaça qu'on n'a pas d'extrait. Il
esest un peu entre l'arbre et
l'l'écorce.
- - Oui mais c'est lui qui s'est
plplacé là v volontairement. C't
unun problèmeme fondamental avec
MoMonsieur autour il est toujous
prpris, coincé entre sa France
exextrêmeme sa France extrêmemey
a a plusieurs de ses députés qui
onont dit des choses extrêmememt
dudures publiquement. Poêlele le
àà c commenter tes. Il n'a pas e
cocontrôlele de son propre cauc.
EtEt ça c'est inévitable dans la
memesure où, comme d'habitude il
nene prend pas une position
clclaire. Il essaie de ménager a
chchèvrvre sanitaire et le chou
d'd'extrêmeme droite dans son p.
CÇa inclut aussi, toute cette
frfrange fondamentale chrétienn.
QuQui est persuadé que Jésus les
prprotègege mieux que les vaccÇa
auaussi on le voit dans le conv.
IlIl y a beaucoup de ce monde-là
dadans son parti. Des pros choi,
cocontre l'obligation vaccinale
sosont aussi pros choix, anti
chchoix à l l'avortement. Son
leleadership, continue de faibl.
- - Ça ne l'aide pas.
- Le chef conservateur est pris
dadans un cercle vicieux. Puis n
reremet son leadership en questn
plplus il apparaît t comme un cf
fafaible auprès s de la populat.
SaSa popularité va diminuer, mas
enen plus pour le changer. Je ne
sasais pas comment il peut cassr
cece cercle là. . Quand on comme
àà a assassiner un chef, ça peut
êêtrtre long et ça finit
gégénéralement mal.
- - Congrès s printemps 2023 das
soson cas. C'est très s loin.
- - Docteur Boileau en solo,
flflanqué de médecins à c côtéte
lului mais on va entendre son
memessage sur la vaccination. Iy
a a bien rien pris garde de ne s
DrDr LUC BOILEAU, dir. national
sasanté publique QC par intérim
- - Quand vous dites que
c'c'est loin d'êtrtre terminé,
atattention. C'est loin d'êtrtre
teterminé avec les données
d'd'en ce moment, mais si tout
lele monde va se faire vacciner,
çaça peut se terminer pas mal
vivite, là. . Donc, c'est vraimt
unun élan qu'on peut se donner
totous pour aller chercher ça.
AlAlors Docteur Boileau qui dit
MaMartine, je ne vais pas dire
c'c'est une bonne idée ou pas.
ElElle va commenter indécis fons
sasamedi à Q Québec.
- - Je vais juste passer une
pepetite observation sur Monsier
BoBoileau. Il ne représente aucn
dadanger pour les politiques. Je
memesure. Il y a énormément
DeDe Pascal Bérubé en disant que
ilil était allé plus loin que ce
ququ'il avait demandé.
IlIl a fait un long plaidoyer en
fafaveur de la troisièmeme dose,
totout en disant que non la
vavaccination obligatoire c'état
unune mauvaise idée.
- - Il évite tout ce qui est...
- - dès s le lendemain de sa
nonomination, j'avançais que
c'c'était une bonne nomination.
SuSur un certain nombre de plan.
IlIl ne sera pas, non seulementl
n'n'embarrassera pas le premier
miministre contrairement au
DoDocteur Arruda mais il a de
mamanièrere plus habile de se fe
l'l'écho de premier ministre.
NoNotamment sur les N95 et la
vavaccinations. Ce qui m'a chic
ETET, c'est qu'on a oublié
l'l'éléphant dans la piècece. Oa
bebeaucoup appelé la population
alaller chercher sa troisièmeme
dodose, et il le faut. N'en rese
papas moins que le Québec, depus
l'l'automne a pris énormément de
reretard par rapport à d d'autrs
ététats sur la troisièmeme dosen
sese souviendra qu'il y avait
plplein de experts qui le
dedemandaient. Là m maintenant,e
QuQuébec continu à a accuser un
reretard. Il y a mêmeme d'autres
exexperts commence à a avancer a
popossibilité question notamment
dede mort au Québec c'est aussin
papartie à c cause du retard qun
apappuie dans la troisièmeme do.
DoDonc oui va pour l'appel,
fafaudrait pas ignorer non plus
leles mêmemes les fonds dans la
pipiècece. Tout comme de dire nà
lala vaccination obligatoire des
rérécalcitrants quand on sait qe
leles trois corps seraient des
cocomplotiste. Ça veut dire que
ququoi, on abandonne la
popossibilité de faire vacciner
totoutes ces personnes-là? ? ent
cacas c'était pourquoi abandonnr
çaça, pourquoi abandonner une
auautre possibilité? détendre la
papasseport vaccinal d'un maximm
dede lieu de travail. Et
d'd'activité.
- - Pourtant il est déjà é étenu
papas mal?
- - oui mais les états employése
sosont pas obligés d'êtrtre vacs
ilil y a plein d'endroits qu'ile
l'l'oblige pas.
- - Vous vous misez rien là--
dedessus.
- - C'est la ligne efficace. Le
DoDocteur Bayle Boileau l'a bien
didit ça pourrait se finir plus
vivite la vaccination avancer ps
vivite.
- - Mais en mêmeme temps il a dt
ququ'il n'irait pas vers la
vavaccination obligatoire.
- - Monsieur Boileau est
exextrêmemement habile. Ça c'ese
dédécision de nature économique,
jeje ne me prononcerai pas là--
dedessus mais il a dit aussi toe
memesure aussi qui peut inciter
leles gens à l les faire vaccinr
esest une bonne mesure. Le
gogouvernement dit que c'est
prprécisément ça le but de la
tataxe, la contribution santé.
C'C'est incité les gens à f faie
vavacciner. Il n'a pas dit que
c'c'était une bonne idée, mais l
n'n'a pas été mauvaise des non
plplus.
- - Il laisse une oeuvre
imimpressionniste Monsieur Legat
pepeut choisir. L'opposition, on
vovoit les locutrices les écout.
DODOMINIQUE ANGLADE
chcheffe, Parti libéral du Québc
- - Ça soulèveve mille questions
ce qu'ils nous ont mentionné.
D'D'un point de vue éthique,
d'd'un point de vue légal,
d'd'un point de vue, mêmeme,
dede l'efficacité d'une telle
memesure. Il y a énormément
dede questions qui sont soulevé.
EtEt honnêtetement, moi...
a a priori, je ne vois pas
cocomment on va êtrtre en faveu.
GAGABRIEL NADEAU-DUBOIS, chef
paparlementaire, Québec Solidaie
- - Emmerder les non-vaccinés,
cece n'est pas une stratégie
dede sortie de crise.
C'C'est une stratégie
popolitique d'un gouvernement
ququi a perdu le contrôlele.
DoDonner des amendes
auaux non-vaccinés, ça n'ouvre
papas de lits dans nos hôpipita.
PAPAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON
chchef, Parti québécois
- - Le fardeau de la preuve,
ilil revient au gouvernement
dede nous démontrer qu'il n'a ps
fafait ça parce que des sondages
ininternes lui disaient que
cece serait populaire.
- - Un petit mot là-d-dessus, le
gogouvernement va aller de l'avt
avavec cette taxe pour les noms
vavaccinés.
- - Ce sera un débat à s survei.
C'C'est la dernièrere session
paparlementaire avant le scrutin
dudu 3 octobre. Si son projet de
loloi là-d-dessus n'est pas adoé
auau cours de cette session la.l
memeurt au feuilleton. Est-ce qe
c'c'est un outil politique, si s
paparties de position s'y oppost
ququ'à l la fin, le gouvernement
prprêt t à s sortir un bâilillor
alaller de l'avant avec cette li
lala. C'est vrai qu'il y a des
enenjeux sensibles, notamment la
coconfidentialité des dossiers,e
nene sera pas simple que ça.
- - Politiquement il y a quelque
chchose à s surveiller. José ese
quque vous dîtetes que vous penz
ququi vont foncer malgré tout?
- - le premier ministre semble
tetenir beaucoup mais je pense e
MaMartin a tout à f fait raisone
dédébat va êtrtre très s dur et
prpréférer à l l'Assemblée
nanationale. Selon parce qu'on
s's'en élection évidemment dès e
dédébut de l'automne mais aussi
paparce que c'est une mesure qui
esest très s questionnable sur
plplusieurs plans. Encore une
fofois, l'argument pourquoi
ememmerder les noms vaccinés als
ququ'on pourrait faire autre che
cocomme étant le passeport
vavaccinal, je reviens là-d-des.
JeJe pense que ça va quitter de
mamanièrere assez serrée.
- - Si on étend, comme vous dîts
JoJosé le passeport vaccinal en
plplein de lieux, partout.
PoPourquoi ne pas appeler un cht
unun chat, et de dire que c'est
unune vaccination obligatoire. n
fait part en arrièrere ce qu'one
pepeut pas faire part en avant.
- - Je pense que légalement il
popourrait le faire. Il y aurait
dedes contestations mais en bout
dede ligne il y a d'autres
enendroits sur la planètete quie
sosont pas des gens qui se ficht
cocomplètetement des droits et
lilibertés fondamentales qui l't
fafait. Les tribunaux leur ont
dodonné les raisons. Je pense qe
çaça pourrait arriver. Je pense
quque Monsieur Legault pense qul
pepeut faire l'économie de ça.
PaParce que les situations
s's'améliorent tranquillement ms
ssûrerement. Je voudrais que c't
lala mêmeme chose pour l'attaque
sasanté. Il va mettre le projet,
ilil va le présenter et le faire
dédébattre. Mais je suis loin
d'd'êtrtre certain qu'il seraitt
àà m mettre bâilillon là-d-desse
lele débat fait et que ça
s's'améliore, il s'est que les
gegens sont favorables à c cette
memesure la. Lui il va simplemet
memettre le fardeau sur le dos
d'd'une position qui vont dire n
esest contre c'est épouvantable.
AlAlors que les gens sont pour.l
n'n'aura pas besoin de le faire
adadopter pour obtenir le gain
popolitique du projet.
- - Je voulais pas les troisième
etet ça va êtrtre une autre foi.